Let's now take a look at the
second important fundamental design goal on the internet,
interconnection, and how interconnection is achieved with the
design principle called the Narrow Waist. Let's keep
in mind that one of the main goals
was to interconnect many existing networks, and to
hide the underlying technology of interconnection from applications.
This design goal was achieved, using a principle
called the narrow waist. The internet architecture,
has many protocols that are layered, on top
of one another. At the center, is an
interconnection protocol, called IP. Or the internet protocol.
Now every internet device must speak IP or have an IP stack. Given that a device
implements the IP stack, it can connect to
the internet. This layer of the network is
sometimes called the network layer. Now this layer provides
guarantees to the layers above. On top of the
network layer sits the transport layer. The transport layer
includes protocols like TCP and UDP. The network layer
provides certain guarantees to the transport layer. One of
those guarantees is end to end connectivity. For example,
if a host has an IP address, then the
network layer, or IP, provides the guarantee that a
packet with that host destination IP address, should
reach the destination with the corresponding address. With
best effort. On top of the transport layer
sits the application layer. The application layer includes
many protocols that various internet applications use. For
example, the web uses a protocol called the
hypertext transfer protocol or HTTP. And mail uses
a protocol called SMTP or simple mail transfer protocol.
Transport layer protocols provide various guarantees to the
application layer. Including reliable transport or congestion control.
Now below the network layer, we have other
protocols. The link layer provides point to point connectivity,
or connectivity on a local area network. In
common link layer protocol, is Ethernet. Below that,
we have the physical layer, which include protocol
such as sonnet or optical networks and so forth.
The physical layer is sometimes called layer 1. The link
layer is sometimes called layer 2 and the network layer
is sometimes called layer 3. We tend to not refer
to layers above the network layer by number. The most
critical aspect of this design is that the network layer
essentially only has one real protocol in use, and that's
IP. That means, that every device on the network must
speak IP, but as long as the device speaks IP
it can get on the internet. This is sometimes called
IP over anything, or anything over IP, now the advantage to
the narrow waist as I mentioned is that it is fairly
easy to get a device on the network if it runs
IP, but the drawback is that because every device is
running IP, it's very difficult to make any changes at this
layer. However, people are trying to do so, and later in
the course, when we discuss software defined networking, we will explore
how various changes are being made to both
the IP layer, and other layers that surround it.